the Joe Rogan experience updated news on
another story
Harvey Weinstein indicted on new sex
crimes in Los Angeles you just want a
trial today in New York on his other
charges these new charges just dropped
in an hour ago Jesus what kind of sex
crimes sexual assault charges one woman
sexually assaulting another in separate
incidents over a two-day period in 2013
who allegedly raped a woman okay so he
still has charges against him I thought
for some reason all these charges have
been okay he's on trial in New York and
this is a separate thing here and then
what they should do with him they should
get him they said listen we're willing
to be more lenient on you but we want to
get you in a room just clad in a
jumpsuit and we're gonna give you a high
dose of MDMA and we're just gonna talk
to you Harvey about how you feel about
people and why you lash out and how did
this all get started what's true and
what's not true what did you do to
people and what what what did people
willingly do and is that is that the
same thing that's where it gets weird
it's like sex as a transaction is one of
the it's it's one of the weirder things
about people is that you can do that
like it's almost like everyone's a drug
dealer right like if someone wants to
[ __ ] you the drug is sex like that
feeling of sex like that people love it
they love it everybody loves it so if
someone knew that other people love it
and then get something to let those
other people do it and we go no you
can't you can't
why can't you but you're doing it anyway
just by virtue of your looks right if
you're just if you're just trying to be
successful on being good-looking in a
lot of ways you're it's like the entry
level of that game like you're doing
you're looking good so that people give
you things you're looking good so that
people pay you if you want to be like a
professional hot chick or a mom
or you know you're you're looking good
and then people pay you because you're
looking good and we're all like we have
no problem with that everyone feels no
problem with that but if you go and do
that and then use your body say I like
looking good because I can get things
but if I use my body I get more things
so I've been using my body word you
can't use your body you can't what is
that we can't imagine if gold diggers it
was encouraged and guys liked it to know
like a bunch of old dudes I didn't care
and then it was all free on the internet
like that everybody would give out
information you just I'll take care of
your right come over here in Johnson if
we just made deals like transactional
deals keep it clean that's pretty much
what girls do but no but you can't do it
legally this is my point is like we came
like webcam stuff there's so many lazy
girls out there that don't want how to
take a job if they can get 2,000 bucks
for blowing some old dude they be in on
that nothing wrong with that though
that's my position nothing wrong with
that do you think we'll see that legal
soon like that that should be stopped so
nobody wants their daughter to be a
[ __ ] the [ __ ] you talk but it's one of
those things it's a hypocritical even of
course it should be legal everything
should be legal of course you don't want
your daughter to be a hooker but of
course everything should be legal that
doesn't see if it's illegal people are
still gonna want it so if they're gonna
want it then you're gonna get it where
it's illegal and you're gonna get
criminals people that can go to jail
they're gonna be the ones that are
providing these girls with protection
they're gonna be the ones that also
dictate how much money the girls make
and how much money they take and we all
know what happens there I mean that's
pimp 101 they we all seen pimps up hoes
down right right right
and the other zone American pimp was
that the other one it was a great one -
this is if it was legal these girls
would be protected they'd probably have
the exact same amount of people that
were paying for it actually more would
paid for it for sure if it became legal
what am I talking about at that spot
next to the comic store used to be a
brothel was what katana
yeah katana was a brothel to watch that
the Sunset Strip documentary maybe back
in the 30s probably it was a while a
while ago beautiful it's a beautiful
place smells good the imagine was like
back then people just like Bugsy Siegel
they own the Comedy Store you know right
yeah that was Bugsy Siegel's place he
imagined people just got whacked back
then shut the [ __ ] up no everyone had a
shovel in their trunk the old photos of
the stars and stuff that would go to
that herbs insane insane
[Applause]